when it comes to taking a loss how do
you how do you deal with a loss and how
do you not let it affect you for how
long how long until it's in your head
Mikey and then you're just like I'm done
you move forward does it linger to your
next fight like how do you how do you
deal with that that's actually a really
really awesome question because the the
best part about mixed martial arts is
the lifestyle that we get to live where
we only fight two to three times a year
maybe four times a year every now and
again now and again and if you're and if
you built a great career and you and you
have great fight persons and you have
good sponsors and you're able to make a
great living you don't want to be in
training camp the whole year you want to
have some down time
but on the flip side of that that very
positive is also a very big negative
because we talk about the sport of
wrestling or stand-up comedy you might
do two shows in a row and you might do a
show of five weeks in a row or five you
know so you take an L one night and
people are booing you or they're
throwing whatever you throw tomatoes
yeah whatever yeah I've seen people
throwing batteries yeah
and you just yeah you feel like hey this
isn't working out I am a loser right 100
but then you get an opportunity very
soon to get back on stage and right that
wrong wrestling was the same thing if I
lost a dual meet on Wednesday we're
gonna wrestle again on Saturday I can
get back in the win column and I can
move forward so the problem or the the
the hardest part about mixed martial
arts is when you do take a loss not only
are you most likely in pain maybe you
got some stitches maybe you got some
swelling maybe you're limping around you
know
you then you then you see all the media
and then you see people's you know
people's reaction and that kind of stuff
and you try not to let it get to you and
you don't get the opportunity to right
that wrong for three four five six one
in eight months so and and I and I
actually I actually uh had a had a a
part of my story I went 688 days without
winning a fight wow I was the Bellator
Champion I lost to Eddie Alvarez I lost
I lost my first fight and in that moment
that small guy from the small town for
who was taught to do small things who I
thought I had duct taped to the basement
of my mind yeah yeah crept back in and
said I told you you were in a monster I
told you you weren't good I told you
everything that they said about you was
Far false everything that you believed
about yourself was false and that loss
turned into another loss and then
another loss and I lost three three
fights in a row and I had to do a lot of
work to get back to believing in myself
and believing that I was created and
destined for great things so so the the
great thing thing about this mixed
martial arts life is we do get time off
between fights but it's you know when
you take a loss
you know there's sometimes you take a
you get an awesome win like my Tony
Ferguson fight I was on top of the world
like man I'm kind of kind of ready to
get back kind of ready to get back in
there I would love to like keep this
momentum going get the kid toward the
title shot
um and then there's some wins where
you're like okay I'm gonna rest on these
coattails for just a second let me let
me come out because you got to remember
you're also talking to somewhat of a
robot right now I'm in training camp and
I gotta do all these things that I have
to do and and you wouldn't get the same
me
luckily I'm able to compartmentalize it
when I'm able to have an awesome
platform like this and thank you for
giving me this but I am somewhat of a
robot and you want to pull yourself away
from that my son doesn't my sons don't
want to you know my son's half doesn't
want to play in the backyard with a
robot when I go home this weekend I'm
going to be a little bit different daddy
than I normally am because I'm in
training camp and I'm focused and I try
to compartmentalize it and I don't do a
great job of it at that same time same
thing with my wife same thing with my
new baby Ace
um
so congratulations congratulations Mike
and this is your second this is your
second kid you adopted bro God bless
thank you good on you bro that's amazing
yeah he was born he was born two and a
half weeks before the Tony Ferguson
folks oh Wow Wow Mike yeah it's very
powerful what you just said because all
right so if you play in the NBA you play
the NFL the MLB hockey whatever the
soccer there's a game the next day the
next week the next yeah you go three six
nine 12 months without a w without a
fight yeah that's I mean in in wrestling
or UFC and boxing that's got a way on
you more than any other sport yeah right
it is it is very it is very tough it is
and that's I think that's the hardest
part about it and also from a longevity
standpoint you do take a loss no matter
what we need even if I went in there and
got caught in a submission it was just a
choke or something somewhat benign and
it didn't take a lot of damage in the
first 30 seconds I still went the last
eight ten weeks sparring two three times
a a week and I'm taking damage I'm
taking damage right now before the the
fight even happens and I've gotten very
I think very methodical and smart about
how I train who I train with the
training partners that I go with I'm not
going to say oh hey this is a brand new
guy who's a world champion kickboxer
from Amsterdam let me go ahead and test
myself yeah I don't need to test I I've
done my tests people know I'm tough
people know I I swing I swing and I'm
fine uh I'd rather be training in a safe
manner with a smile on my face in
not in that fight or flight mode and be
thinking about it and then when I get in
there once again going back to I can
trust myself and know that I can pull
that guy out of me so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]